Feeling a little frazzled as 2025 comes to a close? Put your to-do list on pause and join me for an evening of science, storytelling, and connection. I'm bringing Hidden Brain's Perceptions Tour to the Orpheum Theater in Los Angeles on November 22nd. I'll be sharing seven key psychological insights from the first decade of the show. To get your tickets, go to hiddenbrain.org slash tour. I'm also excited to announce that we are adding more dates to the tour for 2026. I'll be in Philadelphia on March 21st and New York City on March 25th. Hidden Brain listeners get first cracket tickets to those shows.
2025年接近尾声，你是否感到有些精疲力竭？放下你的待办事项清单，加入我，共度一个充满科学、故事与连接的夜晚。11月22日，我将把《Hidden Brain》的“感知之旅”带到洛杉矶的奥菲姆剧院。我将分享该节目开播第一个十年中的七个核心心理学见解。要获取门票，请访问 hiddenbrain.org 斜杠 tour。我还要高兴地宣布，我们正在为2026年的巡演增加更多日期。我将于3月21日前往费城，3月25日前往纽约市。《Hidden Brain》的听众可以优先购买这些演出的门票。
The presale begins at 3 p.m. Eastern on November 3rd and runs through November 5th. To get your tickets to our 2026 shows, go to Hiddenbrain.org slash tour and use the promo code, Brain. No promo code is needed after November 5th. I hope to see you there. And here's today's show. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. When we are facing struggles with our thoughts or our emotions, many of us turn first to medication or therapy as solutions. The share of American adults reporting they took prescription drugs for mental health condition stood at 19% in 2022. That's according to an analysis of government data by the Kaiser Family Foundation.
预售将于美国东部时间11月3日下午3点开始，一直持续到11月5日。要购买我们2026年演出的门票，请访问 Hiddenbrain.org 斜杠 tour，并使用优惠码：Brain。11月5日之后无需优惠码。我希望在那里见到你。以下是今天的节目。这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。当我们面对思想或情绪上的挣扎时，我们许多人首先转向药物或治疗作为解决方案。根据凯撒家庭基金会（Kaiser Family Foundation）对政府数据的分析，2022年，声称因心理健康问题服用处方药的美国成年人比例达到了19%。
That's millions of people taking drugs for anxiety, for depression, for attention deficit disorder. Millions more are in therapy, working through their challenges with a counselor. For many people, such measures are enormously helpful, even a essential. At the same time, it may be the case that we are overlooking a potential source of relief that is literally right outside our door. This remedy costs nothing, has no known side effects, and is often delightfully pleasant. We are talking about spending time in nature. The capacity of the natural world to soothe and refresh our sensibilities has been known for centuries. But it's only recently
这意味着数以百万计的人在服用药物来治疗焦虑、抑郁、注意力缺陷障碍。还有数百万人在接受治疗，与咨询师一起克服他们的挑战。对许多人来说，这些措施极其有用，甚至必不可少。与此同时，我们可能忽略了一个潜在的缓解压力的方法，它实际上就在我们的门外。这种疗法不花钱，没有已知的副作用，而且通常令人愉快。我们谈论的是花时间在大自然中。大自然抚慰和刷新我们感官的能力已经为人所知数百年了。但直到最近
that scientists have begun to identify exactly what it is about the outdoors that has such a powerful effect on our moods and our minds. Nature is filled with curved edges. And one thing that we found in our research is that people really like images that have more curved edges, even built images. So images of architectural scenes that don't have any nature in them, If the architecture has more curved edges, people tend to like that architecture more. If you struggle with the ability to think clearly, to focus your attention, to control maladaptive behaviors, this episode and a companion story on Hidden Brain Plus are definitely for you. Why Nature is Good Medicine.
科学家们才开始准确确定户外究竟是什么对我们的情绪和心智产生如此强大的影响。大自然充满了弯曲的边缘。我们在研究中发现的一件事是，人们非常喜欢具有更多弯曲边缘的图像，甚至是人工建造的图像。因此，对于没有任何自然风光的建筑场景图像，如果建筑有更多弯曲边缘，人们往往会更喜欢这种建筑。如果你在清晰思考、集中注意力、控制适应不良行为方面感到挣扎，这一集以及《Hidden Brain Plus》上的配套故事绝对适合你。为什么大自然是良药。
This week on Hidden Brain. brain. Many of us enjoy an occasional stroll in the park or a hike in the woods. It feels good to see beautiful trees, to hear birds sing, and to breathe fresh air. But might nature offer more than a fleeting respite from our time-pressured, harried lives? At the University of Chicago, psychologist Mark Berman studies how spending time in nature
本周在《Hidden Brain》节目中。我们许多人都喜欢偶尔在公园里散步或在树林里徒步。看到美丽的树木，听到鸟儿歌唱，呼吸新鲜空气，感觉真好。但大自然是否能为我们充满时间压力、匆忙的生活提供超越短暂喘息的东西呢？在芝加哥大学，心理学家马克·伯曼（Mark Berman）研究了花时间在大自然中
can help our minds. Mark Berman, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me on the show. I want to start with a few examples of the phenomenon you've been studying, Mark. In the late 1930s and early 1940s, the artist Jackson Pollock was living and working in New York City.
如何帮助我们的心智。马克·伯曼，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。谢谢你邀请我参加节目。马克，我想从你一直在研究的几个现象的例子开始。在20世纪30年代末和40年代初，艺术家杰克逊·波洛克（Jackson Pollock）在纽约市生活和工作。
What was a state of mind, especially after his father died in 1933? Well, it wasn't good. You know, Jackson Pollock moved from California to New York to be with his brothers. When his father died, he had, you know, extreme depression and alcoholism. And, you know, he was taking sculpting classes, but he was just not very happy, very mentally disturbed, having a lot of problems with depression and alcoholism. I understand that Jackson Pollock's volatility combined with this heavy drink,
他的精神状态如何，特别是1933年他父亲去世后？嗯，情况不太好。你知道，杰克逊·波洛克从加利福尼亚搬到纽约去和他的兄弟们在一起。当他父亲去世时，他有，你知道的，极度的抑郁和酗酒问题。而且，你知道，他当时在上雕塑课，但很不快乐，精神非常困扰，有许多关于抑郁和酗酒的问题。据我了解，杰克逊·波洛克反复无常的性格加上酗酒，
led to some very public and private meltdowns? Yes, at an art gallery, he yelled that he was a much better artist than anyone that had their art being displayed in the art gallery, and subsequently, he lost the ability to be in that art gallery. He got into an argument one time and was so angry that he turned over a whole table that had all of the food, on the table and like 12 roast beef dinners were just flying all over the place that it was a huge mess essentially ending the dinner party right then and there. So at one point he gets romantically involved with a painter Lee Krasner who wants to get him away from New York City. What was her plan now, Mark?
导致了一些非常公开和私人的崩溃？是的，在一个艺术画廊里，他大喊大叫，说自己比任何在艺术画廊展出作品的艺术家都要优秀得多，随后，他失去了进入那个艺术画廊的资格。他有一次陷入争吵，愤怒到掀翻了一整张摆满食物的桌子，桌上有大约12份烤牛肉晚餐四处飞溅，成了一团糟，基本上就在当场结束了晚宴。因此，在某个时候，他与画家李·克拉斯纳（Lee Krasner）产生了浪漫情愫，而她想把他带离纽约市。马克，她的计划是什么？
I think she wanted to get him out of the New York environment where, you know, there were so many bars that he frequented to remove him from that environment, maybe also removing him from some of the people that he was hanging around at the time, and to maybe sort of take him to a more natural, a quieter environment out in Long Island, that the fresh air might be good for him. Do you know what this place was like that they ended up moving out to? I think it was like in Springs, Long Island, which is in East Hampton. And it was a pretty modest home, but it had like a barn and maybe an acre of land. There was a lot of sort of beautiful nature to look at. And it did seem to inspire some changes. Jackson. What changes? He was no longer as volatile. He was no longer as depressed. And it seemed like being in that environment was also quite inspirational for his artwork. He would purchase these large yachting
我想她想让他离开纽约的环境，你知道，那里有他经常光顾的许多酒吧，将他从那个环境中移除，也许也让他远离当时和他混在一起的一些人，也许是带他去长岛一个更自然、更安静的环境，那里的新鲜空气可能对他的健康有益。你知道他们最后搬到的那个地方是什么样的吗？我想它在长岛的斯普林斯（Springs），位于东汉普顿。那是一栋相当简朴的房子，但有一个谷仓和大约一英亩的土地。有很多美丽的自然风光可以欣赏。这确实似乎激发了杰克逊的一些改变。什么改变？他不再那么反复无常了。他不再那么抑郁了。而且身处那样的环境中似乎也对他的艺术创作起到了相当大的启发作用。他会购买这些大型的游艇
canvases and he would spread them out in the barn in the backyard of his home. And he started to do his famous, you know, paint splattering where he would spill the paint and do different things with brushstrokes that were more organic and matched the organic properties of nature. And I think people think that being out in nature inspired this new art form for him. Now, I understand that he continued to have trouble the rest of his life. So it's not like being out in nature was a panacea. It's not like he basically, you know, turned over a completely new leaf. But it did sound as if he got his life together, partly as a result, by being out in nature.
画布，并将它们铺在他家后院的谷仓里。他开始进行他著名的，你知道的，泼墨创作，他会把颜料泼洒出来，并用更具机的、符合大自然有机属性的笔触做出不同的尝试。我想人们认为身处大自然激发了对他而言的这种新艺术形式。现在，据我了解，他在余生中继续遇到麻烦。所以这并不是说身处大自然是一剂万灵药。并不是说他基本上，你知道的，翻开了全新的一页。但听起来他确实重整了生活，部分结果归功于置身大自然。
That's right. And, you know, we would never argue that depression or alcoholism are easy problems to solve. But it does seem to be the case that people's interactions with nature can be very beneficial for people who are suffering from depression and anxiety or ADHD, even things like PTSD. So while, yes, I wouldn't say that being in nature can solve all these problems, it does seem to be the case that being and interacting with nature can help with many of these problems. In more recent years, Mark, the Naval Health Research Center in San Diego, California has run a program to treat members of the U.S. military. What kind of
没错。而且，你知道，我们绝不会争辩说抑郁或酗酒是容易解决的问题。但事实似乎是，人们与大自然的互动对那些遭受抑郁、焦虑或多动症（ADHD），甚至创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）等问题困扰的人非常有利。所以，是的，虽然我不会说置身大自然能解决所有这些问题，但身处大自然并与之互动似乎确实有助于解决其中许多问题。马克，近年来，加利福尼亚州圣迭戈的海军健康研究中心开展了一个项目，旨在治疗美国军人。什么样的
of problems are these veterans struggling with? Often they have problems that involve maybe developing depression or post-traumatic stress disorder, PTSD. Some of them have traumatic brain injury or TBI. There's a lot of, you know, physical and mental health conditions that unfortunately a lot of these service members develop from their time in the military. So the psychologists who work with this population take an unusual approach to treatment. What did they do? Yeah, so they actually had about 20 or so of these military veterans engage in a six-week surf therapy therapeutic session where for three or four hours in a group setting in a southern California beach, they taught these veterans how to surf
问题是这些退伍军人正在与之斗争的？通常他们面临的问题可能涉及患上抑郁症或创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。其中一些人患有创伤性脑损伤（TBI）。有许多，你知道的，生理和心理健康状况，不幸的是，许多这些军人在服役期间患上了这些疾病。因此，与这一群体合作的心理学家采取了一种不同寻常的治疗方法。他们做了什么？是的，他们实际上让大约20名左右的退伍军人参加了为期六周的冲浪治疗疗程，在南加州海滩的集体环境中持续三到四个小时，他们教这些退伍军人如何冲浪
thinking that this kind of program could actually be beneficial to them from a mental and physical health perspective. I'm curious, why surfing? That's a good question. I think in part because they had some feeling that being in nature might be beneficial. So being out in the ocean, seeing the ocean waves, being on the beach, having the sights, smells,
认为这种项目实际上可以从心理和生理健康的角度对他们有所帮助。我很好奇，为什么是冲浪？这是一个好问题。我想部分原因是因为他们有一种预感，即身处大自然可能会有益。因此，置身于海洋中，看着海浪，在海滩上，拥有视觉、嗅觉、
and even the textures of the ocean could be beneficial. It was also somewhat of a social activity because they were taking these veterans out in groups of about 20 people. And, you know, when you're trying to catch a wave, sometimes there's a lot of sitting on your board waiting to catch your wave. And, of course, too, there's also an exercise component to it. Surfing is challenging. It's a hard physical exercise.
甚至是海洋的触感都会有益。这也是一种社交活动，因为他们将这些退伍军人分成大约20人的小组带出去。而且，你知道，当你试图抓浪时，有时会有很多时间坐在冲浪板上等待抓浪。当然，其中也有锻炼的成分。冲浪是具有挑战性的。这是一项艰苦的体力锻炼。
And I think they probably also thought that that would be helpful as well. So the psychologists at the Naval Health Research Center wrote up the results of the surf therapy program in a joint. Journal article published in 2019, what did they report? They found that PTSD symptoms and depression symptoms went down when these surfers were involved in the program, and they also had sort of improved mood, so more positive mood, less negative mood,
我想他们可能也认为这会有所帮助。因此，海军健康研究中心的心理学家在一篇于2019年发表的联合期刊文章中撰文报道了冲浪治疗项目的结果，他们报告了什么？他们发现，当这些冲浪者参与该项目时，PTSD症状和抑郁症状有所下降，他们还改善了情绪，即更积极的情绪，更少的消极情绪，
and that the severity of their depression and anxiety symptoms tended to decrease amongst these surf therapy participants. I understand that you yourself sought solace and comfort in nature when you were a stressed-out graduate student at the University of Michigan. Where would you go when you were feeling at your wit's end mark? Yeah, the two main places that I would go to were Barton Park that was kind of right on the Huron River in Ann Arbor, Michigan. And I would also often go to the Anaritan.
并且这些冲浪治疗参与者的抑郁和焦虑症状的严重程度往往有所降低。据我了解，当你还在密歇根大学做一个压力山大的研究生时，你自己也曾在自然中寻求慰藉和安慰。马克，当你感到山穷水尽时，你会去哪里？是的，我主要去的两个地方一个是巴顿公园（Barton Park），它就在密歇根州安娜堡的休伦河（Huron River）畔。我经常还会去
Botanical Gardens, which was a little bit farther away from campus, a little bit farther away from where I lived, but a very beautiful botanical garden that had a lot of nature trails that you could walk on. I understand there was one particular tree at Barton Park that caught your eye? Yeah, there was this, you know, gigantic oak tree kind of in the middle of the trail on Barton Park. It was almost kind of off by itself, this kind of... singular oak tree that had a really, really giant trunk. And it always kind of caught my eye.
安娜堡植物园（Botanical Gardens），它离校园稍微远一点，离我住的地方稍微远一点，但那是一个非常美丽的植物园，里面有很多你可以步行的自然小径。据我了解，巴顿公园里有一棵特别的树吸引了你的眼球？是的，有一棵，你知道的，巨大的橡树，大约在巴顿公园小径的中间。它几乎有点孤零零的，这棵...独特的外观、树干非常非常巨大的橡树。它总是吸引我的眼球。
You definitely could hear the wind kind of rustling through its leaves. And, you know, sometimes I even felt like I would kind of, you know, talk to this majestic tree that I kind of would anthropomorphize this tree that it could listen to me and maybe kind of help me sort out some of my problems. I understand that toward the end of your time in graduate school, your long-time girlfriend broke up with you. Tell me what happened and the effect this had on you, Mark. Yeah, it was very difficult, and I'm sure a lot of people have experienced difficult breakups, but it was, you know, one of my more serious relationships. And maybe I thought
你绝对能听到风吹过它的树叶沙沙作响。而且，你知道，有时我甚至觉得我好像会，你知道的，跟这棵雄伟的树说话，我把这棵树拟人化了，觉得它能听懂我说话，也许能帮我理清我的一些问题。据我了解，在研究生生涯接近尾声时，你交往很久的女友和你分手了。马克，告诉我发生了什么以及这对你产生了什么影响。是的，这非常困难，我确信很多人都经历过艰难的分手，但这是，你知道的，我更认真的恋爱关系之一。也许我认为
this would be a very long-term, you know, relationship, possibly somebody that I would get married to. So that was a big blow to me. And I was seeing friends of mine that were getting married or buying houses or, you know, having kids, they all seemed to be kind of passing me. So it was a very kind of hard time. A lot of things compounded where it did seem like, you know, a lot of my friends were passing me by and I was kind of stuck still maybe being a kid, not really having grown up yet. I'm wondering how you dealt with this breakup and whether nature played any role in you
这将是一段非常长期的，你知道的，恋爱关系，很可能是我会结婚的人。所以这对我是个沉重的打击。我看到我的朋友们结婚、买房，或者，你知道的，生孩子，他们似乎都超越了我。所以那是一个非常艰难的时期。很多事情叠加在一起，看起来确实，你知道的，我的很多朋友都在超越我，而我却好像还卡在原地，可能像个孩子，还没有真正长大。我想知道你是如何处理这场分手的，大自然是否在其中扮演了任何角色
finding yourself? Well, it certainly did. I immediately went to Barton Park and looked for that big oak tree to share my sorrow and try to see if that oak tree could heal me a bit. Standing beneath the majestic branches
让你找到自我？嗯，它当然有。我立刻去了巴顿公园，寻找那棵大橡树来分享我的悲伤，并试图看看那棵橡树是否能治愈我一点。站在雄伟的树枝
and the gently rustling leaves, Mark confided his sorrow. to the tree. I basically said, you know, it's over with me and Heather. Now I've got to move out and find a new place to live. I'm single. I don't have much money and I'm nearly 30. My friends are buying houses. They're getting married. They're having kids themselves.
和轻轻沙沙作响的树叶下，马克向树倾诉了他的悲伤。我基本上说，你知道的，我和希瑟（Heather）结束了。现在我必须搬出去找个新地方住。我是单身。我没有太多钱，快30岁了。我的朋友们在买房子。他们结婚了。他们自己生孩子了。
You know, I just felt like a loser and, you know, kind of thinking, what am I doing wrong? What was the effect of saying this to the tree? Well, initially it didn't help too much, but I think it felt good to get it out. When you're in front of majestic nature, and to me this tree was fairly awe-inspiring, it does sort of make your problems feel a little bit smaller that were part of something larger and, the vastness of nature can make us feel small, but I think in a good way,
你知道，我只是觉得自己像个失败者，并且，你知道的，心想，我到底哪里做错了？对树说这些话有什么效果？嗯，最初并没有太大帮助，但我认为把话说出来感觉很好。当你面对雄伟的大自然时，对我来说这棵树相当令人敬畏，它确实会让你的问题感觉稍微小一点，让你觉得你是更宏大事物的一部分，而且，大自然的广阔能让我们感到渺小，但我认为是以一种好的方式，
where we realize, you know, we're part of something bigger. And, you know, while I certainly was not feeling good at the time that it would pass, and I would get back to being myself again. You know, sometimes when I'm out in the woods and I see one of these trees that's been around for 50, 60, 70, 80 years, I can't help but think about all the things that this tree has seen and all of the historical events that it's witnessed. I mean, there are trees around that are 200 years old, and you realize that they have seen and been around so much. And in some ways, as you talk to the tree about your breakup, you're putting things in perspective, not just spatially, but also in a question of time.
我们意识到，你知道，我们是更大事物的一部分。而且，你知道，虽然我当时确实感觉不好，但它会过去的，我会恢复成原来的自己。你知道的，有时当我在树林里看到这些已经存在了50、60、70、80年的树木时，我禁不住会去想这棵树所看到过的一切以及它见证过的所有历史事件。我的意思是，周围有200岁的老树，你意识到它们已经见证并经历了那么多。在某些方面，当你向树诉说你的分手时，你不仅在空间上，而且在时间的问题上，把事情放在了视角中。
Yeah, I think that's a really, really good point. And also, too, that you're describing these trees that can be so old. They do kind of have sort of the wisdom of a grandparent. It seems like, you know, they have deep roots. They have a long history. it seems like there is some wisdom that's contained in these trees. An artist finds relief from his roiling emotions and destructive drinking alongside a creek in rural Long Island.
是的，我认为这是一个非常非常好的观点。而且，你也在描述这些可以如此长寿的树木。它们确实有点像祖父母的智慧。看起来，你知道的，它们根基深厚。它们有悠久的历史，看起来这些树木中蕴含着某种智慧。一位艺术家在纽约州农村的一条小溪旁，从他翻腾的情绪和破坏性的酗酒中找到了慰藉。
Military veterans recover from trauma as they surf the waves of the Pacific. And a scientist finds that in the midst of stress and heartbreak, a tree can provide the soothing support he needs. What is it about being outdoors that soothes and heals us, allowing us to become focused and productive? When we come back, the science behind the power of nature to restore our minds. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
退伍军人在冲浪太平洋海浪时从创伤中恢复。一位科学家发现，在压力和心碎之中，一棵树可以提供他所需的舒缓支持。究竟是什么让置身户外舒缓并治愈了我们，使我们能够集中精力并保持高产呢？当我们回来时，探索大自然恢复我们心智力量背后的科学。你正在收听的是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
Have you had experiences in nature that have proved restorative or cleansing? If you have a story about a time in your life when the great outdoors proved helpful to your inner state of mind, please find a quiet room and record a short voice memo. Email it to us at Ideas at HiddenBrain.org. Two or three minutes is plenty. Please use the subject line, nature. Mark Berman. is a psychologist at the University of Chicago.
你在大自然中有过被证明具有恢复力或净化作用的经历吗？如果你有一个关于你生命中的某个时刻，广阔的户外被证明对你的内心状态有帮助的故事，请找一个安静的房间并录制一段简短的语音备忘录。通过电子邮件发送给我们，地址是 Ideas at HiddenBrain.org。两三分钟就足够了。请使用主题行：nature。马克·伯曼
For many years now, he's been interested in the science of why nature seems to help our minds. Mark, one of the leading lights in your field is a man named Roger Ulrich. When he was a teenager, he was often sick. How did he turn to nature to help him? Yeah, he actually told me that when he was a kid or a teenager, he suffered from staff infections and some kidney disease,
是芝加哥大学的心理学家。多年来，他一直对大自然似乎如何帮助我们心智的科学感兴趣。马克，你所在领域的一位领军人物是一个名叫罗杰·乌尔里希（Roger Ulrich）的人。当他还是个青少年时，他经常生病。他是如何转向大自然来帮助自己的？是的，他实际上告诉我，当他还是个孩子或青少年时，他患有葡萄球菌感染和一些肾病，
and he would spend a lot of times, you know, sitting in clinics or hospitals, but he much more enjoyed recuperating at home where he would kind of lie down and out of the window there were a giant pine tree outside his window that he would look at quite often when he was recovering from these illnesses. So he went on to become a researcher,
他会花很多时间，你知道的，坐在诊所或医院里，但他更喜欢在家休养，他会躺下来，窗外有一棵巨大的松树，当他从这些疾病中恢复时，他经常会看着它。所以他后来成为了一名研究员，
and in the early 1980s, he conducted a remarkable study at a hospital in Philadelphia. What did he study and what did he find? Yeah, it's a really incredible study, and I would say one of the most seminal works in kind of environmental psychology. And what Roger did was he studied patient recovery from gallbladder surgery on a single corridor
在20世纪80年代初，他在费城的一家医院进行了一项引人注目的研究。他研究了什么，又发现了什么？是的，这是一项非常不可思议的研究，我会说它是环境心理学领域最具开创性的著作之一。罗杰做的是，他在费城一家医院的
in a hospital in Philadelphia. And what Roger was interested in looking at, were the views out of the windows of these hospital rooms. So some of the hospital rooms had some modest views of nature out of the window, like some trees or some shrubs or some grass. But other rooms on this hospital corridor had views of like a brick wall, of the other side of the hospital. And Roger was interested in seeing,
单一走廊上研究了患者从胆囊手术中的恢复情况。罗杰感兴趣的是观察医院病房窗外的景色。因此，一些病房的窗外有适度的自然景色，比如一些树木、灌木或草地。但这条医院走廊上的其他房间看到的景色是砖墙，也就是医院的另一侧。罗杰有兴趣看看，
does the room that people are in and the view that they have out the window have any impact on recovery from gallbladder surgery? And incredibly, he found that patients that had the views of modest nature out of their window recovered about a day earlier from gallbladder surgery compared to the patients who had rooms of a brick wall. In addition, the patients that had the rooms with the nature view, they used less pain medication than the patients that had the views of the brick wall. And, you know, people might be thinking, well, maybe. patients who were healthier or younger or wealthier maybe they got the views of the of nature and
人们所在的房间以及他们从窗户看出去的景色对胆囊手术的恢复有什么影响吗？令人难以置信的是，他发现窗外有适度自然景色的患者比那些房间面对砖墙的患者从胆囊手术中早恢复大约一天。此外，拥有自然景色房间的患者比面对砖墙景色的患者服用了更少的止痛药。而且，你知道的，人们可能会想，也许
the other patients didn't but that wasn't the case these patients were basically randomly assigned to these different hospital rooms they were just whatever room was available that's the room that they got which is kind of like doing an experiment and it's just amazing that being randomly assigned to the room that had the modest nature view could speed recovery and also cause people to use less pain medication. Roger was really interested also in stress and stress responses. So he believed that interactions with nature could remediate stress responses. And he thought that was the mechanism behind why interacting with nature was having different
更健康、更年轻或更富有的患者得到了自然的景色，而其他患者没有，但事实并非如此。这些患者基本上是随机分配到这些不同的医院病房的，他们只是分配到哪个可用房间就是哪个房间，这有点像做一个实验，真了不起，随机分配到拥有适度自然景色的房间就能加速恢复，并导致人们使用更少的止痛药。罗杰也非常关注压力和压力反应。因此，他认为与大自然的互动可以补救压力反应。他认为这是与大自然互动产生不同
beneficial effects. Over time, many other theories have been advanced about why nature could have positive effects on our minds. One came from the evolutionary biologist E.O. Wilson. He called it the biophilia hypothesis. So the biophilia hypothesis in a nutshell is this idea that humans have an inherent love of nature and the natural world and other. living organisms, you know, and these tend to be places that we would say would be very good habitats for humans to live in. And there was actually a researcher, Jay Appleton, who proposed this other theory called prospect refuge theory, that environments that had high prospect, meaning, you know, places where you could draw food and water, but also that had high refuge, places where you could
有益效果背后的机制。随着时间的推移，人们提出了许多其他理论，解释为什么大自然会对我们的心智产生积极影响。其中一个来自进化生物学家E·O·威尔逊（E.O. Wilson）。他称之为生物ophilia假说（生物亲和假说）。简而言之，生物ophilia假说就是这样一个观点：人类对大自然、自然世界和其他
kind of hide and be safe would be the most kind of preferred environments. And that also kind of matches this idea of humans kind of liking natural environments that have a lot of plants and trees, but also water. As you began to conduct your own research in this field, Mark, you were working with a mentor named Stephen Kaplan. Steve believed that the benefits of exposure to nature had much to do with attention. And he would often talk about how humans have two distinct types of attention. What are these two forms of attention? Yeah, so Steve coined or developed this hypothesis called the attention restoration theory, and he did this in partnership with his wife, Rachel Kaplan. And one of the main tenets of
生物有着与生俱来的热爱，你知道的，这些往往是我们认为非常适合人类居住的栖息地的地方。实际上有一位研究员杰伊·阿普ルトン（Jay Appleton），他提出了另一个名为“展望-避难所理论”的理论，即拥有高展望的环境，意味着，你知道的，你可以获取食物和水源的地方，同时也拥有高避难所、你可以
attention restoration theory is that humans have two main kinds of attention. And one kind of attention is called directed attention. And that's the kind of attention where you as the individual person are deciding what to pay attention to. So presumably anybody listening to the show is deciding to pay attention to what we're talking about. And this directed attention is the kind of attention that we use a lot in schools and at work. It's thought to be fatigable or depletable that you can only sort of direct your attention for so long before you become mentally fatigued and you can't really focus anymore. And we've all had that sensation kind of at the end of a long work day where you might be just staring at the computer screen and nothing's
隐藏并保持安全的地方，将是最受偏爱的环境。这也符合人类喜欢拥有大量植物和树木以及水的自然环境的观点。当你开始在这个领域进行自己的研究时，马克，你与一位名叫斯蒂芬·卡普兰（Stephen Kaplan）的导师合作。史蒂夫认为接触大自然的好处很大程度上与注意力有关。他经常谈到人类有两种不同类型的注意力。这两种注意力形式是什么？是的，史蒂夫创造或发展了这个名为注意力恢复理论的假设，这是他与他的妻子雷切尔·卡普兰（Rachel Kaplan）合作完成的。注意力恢复理论的主要信条之一是
really happening and you just can't focus or concentrate to get your work done, we would call that a directed attention fatigue state, and that's a good time to take a break. So Steve argued that there was a second form of attention as well. What is the second form? Right. In the second form of attention, Steve called invariable. voluntary attention. And that's the kind of attention that's automatically captured by interesting stimulation in the environment. So bright lights, loud noises, they automatically capture our attention and we don't really have any control over it. And it's thought that involuntary attention is less susceptible to fatigue or depletion. And you don't often hear people say,
人类有两种主要类型的注意力。其中一种注意力被称为定向注意力。这就是作为个体的人决定将注意力集中在何处的注意力。所以据推测，任何收听这个节目的人都在决定关注我们正在讨论的内容。这种定向注意力是我们在学校和工作中使用很多的注意力。人们认为它是易疲劳的或可耗尽的，你只能将注意力定向一定的时间，然后你就会精神疲劳，真正无法再专注于事物了。我们都有过这样的感觉，在漫长的工作日结束时，你可能只是盯着电脑屏幕，什么都没有
oh, I can't look at that beautiful waterfall anymore. It's just too beautiful. It's too tiring to look at. I have to stop looking at it. So the idea behind attention restoration theory is that if you can find environments that don't place a lot of demands on directed attention, while simultaneously having interesting stimulation that activates the involuntary attention, you could restore or replenish this precious directed attention resource. And we think that a lot of natural environment sort of meet these criteria. Not all forms of involuntary attention are restorative.
真正发生，你只是无法集中精力或专注来完成你的工作，我们称之为定向注意力疲劳状态，这是休息的好时机。因此史蒂夫认为还有第二种形式的注意力。第二种形式是什么？对的。对于第二种形式的注意力，史蒂夫称之为非自主注意力。这就是自动被环境中引人入胜的刺激所吸引的注意力。所以明亮的灯光，巨大的噪音，它们会自动吸引我们的注意力，我们对此真的没有任何控制。人们认为非自主注意力不易受到疲劳或耗尽的影响。你不会经常听到有人说，
Compare the experience of watching ocean waves at a beach, for example, to the experience of walking through Times Square in New York City. When you're looking at those waves at the ocean, it captures your involuntary attention, but it doesn't really capture all of your attentional resources. You can kind of mind wander and think about other things while you're looking at those waves. When you're walking through Times Square, it's also very interesting.
哦，我再也不能看那个美丽的瀑布了。它太美了。看它太累了。我必须停止看着它。因此，注意力恢复理论背后的想法是，如果你能找到不给定向注意力提出太多要求的环境，同时又具有激活非自主注意力的有趣刺激，你就可以恢复或补充这种宝贵的定向注意力资源。我们认为许多自然环境在某种程度上符合这些标准。并非所有形式的非自主注意力都具有恢复作用。
There's a lot of really interesting stimulation in Times Square that automatically captures involuntary tension, but it sort of captures all of your attentional resources. You can't really mind wander or think about other things when you're in Times Square. And Stephen Rachel thought that that kind of stimulation is not really going to be able to rest our directed attention abilities at it, that it might actually fatigue us even further. the sky allows our minds to relax, to wander. These softly fascinating scenes are very different
例如，将观看海滩海浪的体验与穿过纽约市时代广场的体验进行比较。当你看着大海的波浪时，它会吸引你的非自主注意力，但它并没有真正占用你所有的注意力资源。当你看着那些波浪时，你可以漫无目的地神游并思考其他事情。当你穿过时代广场时，它也非常有趣。
than the harsh demands of being in a hyper-stimulating environment like Times Square. You cannot let your attention wander. You might get bumped into by hordes of tourists or run over by a cab. Scientists have also theorized that natural landscapes and soundscapes are just more easily absorbed by our brains. There are certain simulation in the environment that our brains process more fluently, that it's just easier to process certain stimulation. And that's also kind of related to soft fascination,
时代广场有很多非常有趣的刺激，会自动吸引非自主注意力，但它在某种程度上占用了你所有的注意力资源。当你在时代广场时，你不能真正漫无目的地神游或思考其他事情。斯蒂芬和雷切尔认为，这种刺激实际上无法恢复我们的定向注意力能力，它甚至可能使我们进一步疲劳。天空让我们的心智放松、神游。这些柔和迷人的景象非常不同
that softly fascinating stimulation might also be sort of easier to process. But what does that really mean? And so we've started to try to quantify what it means for different stimulation to be processed more fluently or more. easily. And it seems like that seems to be occurring more for natural images versus urban images. You know, it's interesting. As I'm sitting here talking to you, I'm able to look out at a window and I'm seeing a tree. And the tree has, you know, probably 5,000 leaves that I can see right now through the window. But of course, I'm just taking in all of those leaves in one
于身处时代广场等超级刺激环境中的苛刻要求。你不能让你的注意力神游。你可能会被成群的游客撞到，或者被出租车撞倒。科学家还推论，自然景观和声景更容易被我们的大脑吸收。环境中有某些模拟是我们的大脑可以更流利地处理的，处理某些模拟只是更容易。这也与柔和迷人感有关，
big bite. I'm not actually noticing that each of those leaves has a different vein structure and the light is hitting that leaf differently. I'm just taking it in as a tree, and that's what you're talking about here. That's right. That's right. Versus in the urban environment, you might actually be cataloging all the different objects, you know, that there's a Volkswagen Beetle, a bicycle, you know, gothic architecture. And, you know, we're just labeling and quantifying all of that information, which is taking up more room, whereas what you're saying, when you're looking at that tree, you're compressing that representation to just be a tree and not to, you know,
柔和迷人的刺激可能也更容易处理。但这到底意味着什么？因此，我们开始尝试量化不同刺激被更流利或更容易处理意味着什么。这似乎对于自然图像与城市图像来说发生得更多。你知道，这很有趣。当我坐在这里跟你说话时，我能够透过窗户看出去，我看到了一棵树。这棵树有，你知道的，可能5,000片叶子，我现在可以透过窗户看到。但当然，我只是一口气把所有这些叶子都吸收进去了。我实际上并没有注意到每一片叶子都有不同的叶脉结构，光线照在那个叶片上的方式也不同。我只是把它当作一棵树来接受，这正是你在这里谈论的。没错。没错。相比之下，在城市环境中，你实际上可能在对所有不同的物体进行分类，你知道的，那里有一辆大众甲壳虫，一辆自行车，你知道的，哥特式建筑。而且，你知道的，我们只是在标记和量化所有这些信息，这占据了更多的空间，而你所说的，当你看着那棵树时，你将这种表征压缩为只是一棵树，而不是，你知道的，
something that's got 5,000 little extra parts for every single leaf. One particular aspect of natural settings that might affect us is the prevalence of curved edges. Talk about this idea, Mark. Why would this matter? Well, it's interesting that natural settings tend to have more curved edges. You know, if you imagine a tree, a tree's got curvy branches, tend to have curvy leaves, an ocean, the waves are curvy, the coastline is curvy. So nature is filled with curved edges. And one thing that we found in our research is that people really like images that have more curved edges, even built images.
一个对每一片叶子都有5,000个微小额外部分的物体。自然环境的一个特定方面可能会影响我们，那就是弯曲边缘的普遍存在。马克，谈谈这个想法。为什么这很重要？嗯，有趣的是，自然环境往往有更多弯曲边缘。你知道，如果你想象一棵树，树有弯曲的树枝，往往有弯曲的叶子，海洋，波浪是弯曲的，海岸线是弯曲的。所以大自然充满了弯曲边缘。我们在研究中发现的一件事是，人们非常喜欢具有更多弯曲边缘的图像，甚至是人工建造的图像。
So images of architectural scenes that don't have any nature in them, if the architecture has more curved edges, people tend to like that architecture more. Another aspect of natural settings that might affect our minds is the presence of what mathematicians and physicists call fractals. What are fractals, Mark, and how do they show up in nature?
因此，对于没有任何自然风光的建筑场景图像，如果建筑有更多弯曲边缘，人们往往会更喜欢这种建筑。自然环境可能会影响我们心智的另一个方面是数学家和物理学家所称的分形的存在。马克，什么是分形，它们是如何在大自然中表现出来的？
Yeah. So, if we imagine a snowflake, the snowflake has a characteristic shape. If we put that snowflake under a microscope and zoom in, you'll also see some of the same shape. And if you zoom in some more, you also see the same shape. So that it doesn't really matter what spatial scale you look at the snowflake, it's got the same characteristic shape.
是的。所以，如果我们想象一片雪花，雪花具有特征形状。如果我们把那片雪花放在显微镜下并放大，你也会看到一些相同的形状。如果你再放大一些，你也会看到相同的形状。所以无论你以什么空间尺度看雪花，它都具有相同的特征形状。
So we would say then that the snowflake is scale-free. It doesn't matter what spatial scale you look at the snowflake. It's got the same characteristic shape. Or mathematicians would say that that snowflake is more fractal. it's got more of a fractal aspect to it and you can imagine the same thing with a tree a tree has a trunk which then branches out into other branches that branches out into smaller branches they might branch out to even smaller branches that branches out into leaves and then there's a big vein in the leaf that might branch out into into other veins of the leaf and so it might not matter as much at what spatial scale
所以我们就可以说雪花是无标度的。无论你以什么空间尺度看雪花都无所谓。它具有相同的特征形状。或者数学家会说这片雪花更具分形特征。它具有更多的分形方面，你可以对一棵树想象同样的事情，一棵树有一个树干，然后分枝成其他树枝，再分枝成更小的树枝，它们可能会分枝成更小的树枝，分枝成叶子，然后叶子中有一条大脉络，可能会分枝成叶子的其他脉络，所以无论你以什么空间尺度看树，它都可能不那么重要，它有点像这种相同的分枝结构，事实证明大自然充满了这种无标度的或分形的刺激。你认为这些弯曲边缘和分形在大自然对我们心智产生影响中扮演什么角色？可能是弯曲边缘，特别是分形性可能更容易处理。因此，特别是如果我们再次考虑分形，因为它是以不同的尺度重复相同的形状，你可能不需要处理或记住每一个细节，因为它是重复的。但我也认为，而且我们对此并没有所有的答案，
you look at the tree it's kind of got this same branching structure and it turns out nature is filled with this scale-free or fractal stimulation. What do you think the role is of these curved edges and fractals in the effects that nature is having on our minds? It could be that curved edges and in particular a fractalness might be easier to process. So in particular, if we think about the fractals again, because it's the same shape that's kind of repeating at different scales, you may not have to process or remember every single detail because it's repeated. But I also think, too, and we don't have all the answers to this,
这可能与审美偏好有关，人们有点喜欢对称性，这种分形性也具有一些对称属性。人们往往不那么喜欢尖锐的边缘或直线。你可以想象一些人们不太喜欢的建筑往往是非常直角直线的粗野主义建筑。人们往往更喜欢
it might have to do with an aesthetic preference that people kind of like symmetry and this fractalness also has some symmetrical properties. People tend not to like sharp edges or straight lines as much. You can imagine some buildings that people don't enjoy very much tend to be brutalist architecture that's very rectilinear. People tend to prefer
更复杂的哥特式建筑，或者你可以想象高迪在巴塞罗那设计的建筑，非常优美，模仿了大自然的模式。人们似乎真的很喜欢
more Gothic architecture that has more intricacy or you could imagine a building designed by Gaudi in Barcelona that's very curvy, that's mimicking the patterns of nature. People really seem to enjoy
环境中拥有弯曲的结构。当然，我们所有人都曾在树林里、海滩旁或山腰上度过美好的一天，当时天气很好，你知道的，一切看起来都很美。但你发现，即使大自然令人不快，如果你在暴风雪中外出，道路湿滑，人行道结冰，即使在那种情况下，大自然也能为我们带来
having curved structure in the environment. Now, of course, all of us have been out, you know, on a beautiful day in the woods or by a beach or in a mountainside and the weather is great and, you know, everything looks beautiful. But you found that even when nature is unpleasant, if you go out in the middle of a snowstorm and the roads are slick and the sidewalks are icy, even then nature can have
益处。没错。我们测试定向注意力理论的主要研究之一，是将人们带入实验室，给他们一些客观的认知任务来衡量他们的定向注意力能力。其中一项任务被称为倒序数字广度任务。因此，参与者会以每秒约一个数字的速度大声听到数字。比如473。参与者需要以倒序重复这些数字，所以是3，7，4。我们不断增加数字的数量，最多达到九个数字。3，1，5，1，6。在大约五个数字时，任务变得非常困难。因此参与者来到了实验室。我们给他们这个困难的倒序数字广度任务。然后我们给他们一张地图
benefits for us. That's right. One of our major studies where we tested directed attention theory involved bringing people into the laboratory and giving them some objective cognitive task to measure their directed attention abilities. And one of these tasks was called the backwards digit span task. So participants would hear digits out loud at a pace of about one digit per second. So 473. And the participants would need to repeat those digits back in backwards order, so three, seven, four. And we kept increasing the number of digits up to nine digits. Three, one, five, one, six. At around five digits, the task gets very difficult. So participants came to the laboratory. We gave them this difficult backwards digit span task. And then we gave them a map
让他们穿过安娜堡植物园（这是我们的自然漫步），或者让他们穿过繁忙的安娜堡市中心，穿过繁忙的华盛顿大街（Washinaw Avenue），然后参与者返回实验室再次重复这个倒序数字广度任务。主要的效应是，我们发现在自然漫步后，参与者在这个倒序数字广度任务上的能力提高了大约20%，
that either had them walk through the Ann Arbor Arboretum, that was our nature walk, or we had them walk through busy downtown Ann Arbor, through busy Waschinaw Avenue, and then participants returned back to the lab to repeat this backwards digit span task again. The main effect was we found that participants improved their ability on this backwards digit span task by about 20% after the walk in nature,
但在城市环境中漫步后则没有。因此，仅仅在漫步50分钟后，他们的成绩就提高了一个半数字左右。许多人可能会想，这也许只是因为在大自然中散步很愉快，人们真的很喜欢在大自然中散步。确实，参与者大多确实享受在大自然中的漫步。但我们并没有看到人们喜欢散步的程度或他们在自然散步中情绪改善的程度，与他们在工作记忆测试（即这个倒序数字广度任务）中的提升之间存在强烈的相关性。所以并不是说只有那些非常热爱自然漫步的人才表现出最大的进步。更有力的证明是，我们在一年中的不同时间让参与者散步。因此，有些人在6月散步，当时在密歇根州安娜堡气温约为华氏80度，参与者说，哦，马克，我喜欢这次漫步。
but not after the walk in the urban environment. So they improved by about a digit and a half just after a 50-minute walk. And many people might be thinking, well, maybe it's just because walking in nature is pleasant and people really like the walk in nature. And it's true, participants did enjoy the walk in nature for the most part. But we didn't see a strong correlation between how much people like to walk or how much their mood improved on the walk in nature being correlated with their improvements on this
但在城市环境中散步后却没有。因此，在仅仅进行了50分钟的散步后，他们的成绩就提高了大约一个半数字。很多人可能会想，嗯，也许这只是因为在大自然中散步很愉快，人们真的很喜欢在大自然中散步。确实，参与者大多都很享受在大自然中的散步。但是我们没有发现，人们有多喜欢散步，或者他们在自然散步中情绪改善的程度，与他们在这一方面的提升之间存在强烈的相关性。
working memory test, this backwards digit span task. So it wasn't the case that just the people who loved the nature walk so much were the ones who showed the biggest improvement. And an even stronger demonstration of this is that we had participants walk at different times of the year. So some people walked in June when it was about 80 degrees Fahrenheit in Ann Arbor, Michigan, and participants said, oh, Mark, I love the walk.
工作记忆测试，即这个倒序数字广度任务。所以，并不是只有那些极其热爱自然散步的人才表现出最大的进步。更有力的证明是，我们让参与者在一年中的不同时间进行散步。因此，有些人是在六月份散步的，当时密歇根州安娜堡的温度大约是华盛顿温度80度（约26.7摄氏度），参与者们说，哦，马克，我很喜欢这次散步。
I can't believe you're paying me to go for a walk in nature. They showed really healthy mood improvements, and they also showed really healthy improvements to direct attention as measured with this backwards, did it's been task. But we also had people walk in January when it was 25 degrees Fahrenheit and participants said, Mark, I was freezing out there.
真不敢相信你付钱让我去大自然中散步。结果显示，他们的情绪有非常健康的改善，而且根据这项倒序数字广度测试的测量，他们在直接注意力方面也有了非常健康的提升。但我们也让人们在1月气温为华氏25度（零下4摄氏度）的时候去散步，参与者说，马克，我在外面都要冻僵了。
I did not like that walk in nature. But those participants that walked in January showed the same cognitive improvement as the people that walked in June. So sort of the short answer is to get these cognitive benefits, you don't even need to enjoy the nature walk to get the benefit.
我很不喜欢那次大自然中的散步。但那些在1月散步的参与者，展现出了和6月散步的人同样的认知提升。所以简短的回答是，为了获得这些认知益处，你甚至不需要享受大自然的漫步就能获得这些益处。
I mean, that's striking because I think most of us assume that the subjective experience of the walk, the fact that we like the beach, we like the water, we like the sunshine, but I think the study might be arguing that, in fact, the effects that nature is having on our mind are in some ways independent of our enjoyment of it. I think that's right to some extent. So I definitely don't think all of these effects are driven by preference. And you even have people that say, you know, I'm a city lover. I don't like being in nature. And we don't think that really matters. However, I think if we would have sent those participants in January on the walk in nature without a coat and they were so uncomfortable,
我的意思是，这很惊人，因为我认为我们大多数人都认为散步的主观体验——比如我们喜欢海滩、喜欢水、喜欢阳光——但这项研究可能在争论，事实上，大自然对我们心灵的影响在某种程度上与我们是否享受它无关。我认为在某种程度上是这样的。所以我绝对不认为所有这些影响都是由偏好驱动的。你甚至会听到有人说，你知道，我是一个城市爱好者，我不喜欢在大自然中。我们认为这其实没关系。然而，我认为如果我们让那些参与者在1月份穿着大衣去大自然中散步，而他们感到非常不舒服，
I think that would have used a lot of directed attention and they wouldn't have seen the nature effects. or if you're walking, you know, in June and there's so many mosquitoes that you're getting eaten alive and it's so uncomfortable, I don't think we would see the effects. But I think as long as basic safety and comfort needs are met, you don't have to really love the nature interaction
我认为这会消耗大量的直接注意力，他们就不会看到大自然的疗愈效果。或者如果你在6月份散步，你知道，有太多的蚊子把你咬得半死，而且感觉非常不舒服，我认为我们就看不到这些效果了。但我认为，只要基本的安全和舒适需求得到满足，你就不必真的热爱与大自然的互动
to get these cognitive benefits. So you can go on a cloudy day. You could go on a rainy day. You can go on a cold day. As long as your basic safety and comfort for needs are met, we think you can get these benefits. Being in nature boosts our mood, reduces our stress, and restores our attention. When we come back, how we can intentionally harness the power of nature to make our own minds work better.
来获得这些认知益处。所以你可以在阴天去，可以在雨天去，也可以在寒冷的日子去。只要你基本的安全和舒适需求得到满足，我们认为你就能获得这些益处。身处大自然能提升我们的情绪、减轻压力并恢复我们的注意力。稍后我们将探讨如何有意地利用大自然的力量让我们的头脑运转得更好。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Have you had experiences in nature that have proved restorative or cleansing? If you have a story about a time in your life where the great outdoors proved helpful to your inner state of mind, please find a quiet room and record a short voice memo. Email it to us at Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org. Two or three minutes is plenty. Please use the subject line, nature.
您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。你是否有过大自然被证明具有恢复力或净化作用的经历？如果你有一段生活经历，证明大自然对你的内心状态有所帮助，请找一个安静的房间，录制一段简短的语音备忘录。将其发邮件至 Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org。两三分钟就足够了。请使用主题行：nature（自然）。
Mark Berman is a psychologist at the University of Chicago. He's the author of Nature and the Mind, the science of how nature improves cognitive, physical, and social well-being. Mark, when you've been working hard, you like to take a break by watching sports. You once assumed that this activity was relaxing and refreshing, but you don't believe this anymore? no unfortunately i think it actually watching sports um is not really softly fascinating that's a bit harshly fascinating and even when my team won sometimes i would feel a bit irritated uh after watching
马克·伯曼是芝加哥大学的心理学家。他是《自然与心灵：大自然如何改善认知、身体和社交健康的科学》（Nature and the Mind, the science of how nature improves cognitive, physical, and social well-being）一书的作者。马克，当你工作努力时，你喜欢通过看体育节目来休息。你曾认为这种活动既放松又令人精神焕发，但你现在不这么认为了吗？不，不幸的是，我认为实际上看体育比赛，嗯，并不是真正温和地吸引注意力，那是强烈地吸引注意力，甚至有时当我的球队赢了，看完之后我也会觉得有点恼火。
now i still love to watch some of my favorite teams but i don't i don't do that as a as a rest that's not a rest and i think unfortunately there are many other things that we do in the modern world, maybe scrolling social media, looking at our news feed, surfing the internet that might feel like restful activities, but that actually may be depleting activities. You know, I was talking with some friends just a couple of weeks ago, and they were telling me about watching a sports match that was very thrilling and had a very, very dramatic conclusion.
现在我依然喜欢看我的一些最喜欢的球队，但我不再把这当成一种休息，那不是休息。不幸的是，我认为我们在现代社会中做的许多其他事情，比如刷社交动态、看新闻推送、上网，可能感觉像是令人放松的活动，但实际上可能是消耗精力的活动。你知道，就在几周前我和一些朋友聊天，他们跟我说起他们看的一场非常惊心动魄、结局非常非常戏剧性的体育比赛。
And at the end of it, you know, they were describing almost what felt like watching a horror movie because they said, you know, they were literally crouching behind a couch, you know, watching the TV afraid of what it was going to show them or covering their faces and looking at the TV through a small gap in their fingers. And I think that speaks to the idea that this is not, you know, calmly restorative TV watching. That's right. I can sympathize with those feelings. I know what that feels like.
最后，你知道，他们描述的感觉几乎就像在看恐怖电影，因为他们说，你知道，他们真的蹲在沙发后面，看着电视，害怕电视里会出现什么画面，或者捂着脸，透过手指间的缝隙看着电视。我认为这说明了这样一个事实：这并不是那种，你知道的，让人平静恢复精力的电视观看方式。没错。我能理解那种感受。我知道那是什么感觉。
And again, I'm not saying that it's. it's bad or that you want to avoid that at all costs, just don't think of that as being a restful activity because it probably isn't. So, Mark, we know from lots of lines of psychological research that people misjudge what will make them happy. You say that this is the case when it comes to spending time in nature. How so?
再说一次，我并不是说这是坏事，或者你想不惜一切代价避免它，只是不要认为这是一种令人放松的活动，因为它可能并不是。所以，马克，从大量的心理学研究中我们知道，人们会对什么能让自己快乐做出错误判断。你说当涉及到在大自然中度过时间时，情况也是如此。怎么说呢？
Yeah, and there was an interesting study done by some researchers where they asked participants how much do you think you would enjoy going for a walk in nature so they sort of had to had a forecast how much would they like the walk in nature and then they had another group of participants walk in nature and then they asked them after the walk how much did you enjoy the walk in nature and it turns out people really really underestimated
是的，研究人员做过一项有趣的研究，他们问参与者：你觉得自己会有多享受去大自然中散步？所以他们得预测一下自己会有多喜欢这场自然漫步；然后他们让另一组参与者去大自然中散步，散步后问他们：你有多享受这场自然漫步？结果证明，人们大大低估了
how much they would enjoy the walk in nature so their forecasts were wrong you know people enjoyed the walk much more than they forecasted it to be. And that's just about liking the walk. I'm guessing that we also are sort of off in our forecast in terms of how helpful or restorative the walk in nature might be. I'm wondering if this is connected to the fact that nature is softly fascinating, Mark, because, for example, if you asked my friends who watched that very exciting match, was the match exciting, they would have no problem telling you the match was very exciting and was absolutely and absolutely had to be watched. On the other hand, when someone goes for a nice walk,
自己会有多享受大自然的散步，所以他们的预测是错误的，你知道，人们对散步的享受程度远超他们的预测。这还只是喜欢散步本身。我猜我们在预测大自然的散步会有多大帮助或多大恢复作用时，也有些偏差。马克，我想知道这是否与大自然能温和地吸引注意力这一事实有关？因为，举个例子，如果你问那些看了那场非常精彩的比赛的朋友，比赛精彩吗？他们会毫不犹豫地告诉你比赛非常精彩，而且绝对、绝对值得一看。另一方面，当有人去进行一次美好的散步时，
precisely because it's softly fascinating, it hasn't captured our attention. If you ask someone to forecast how exciting the next walk is going to be, how fun it's going to be, we underestimate it. Right. I think that could be part of it, definitely, that softly fascinating stimulation might be sort of less enjoyable or less exciting than this more harshly fascinating stimulation. But that's also part of the phenomenon of the why it might work, that it is more restful to go for the walk in nature,
恰恰因为它是温和吸引注意力的，它并没有完全抓住我们的注意力。如果你让某人预测接下来的散步会有多精彩、会有多有趣，我们往往会低估它。没错。我认为这可能是原因的一部分，毫无疑问，这种温和吸引注意力的刺激可能比这种强烈吸引注意力的刺激更不那么令人享受或不那么刺激。这也是为什么它管用的现象的一部分，那就是去大自然中散步会更有恢复精力的效果，
even if it's not as enjoyable as doing something else that might be more harshly fascinating. We've been talking a lot about how we're affected by what we see outdoors, but your research has looked at the sounds of nature and how they can make a difference. What do you find, Mark?
即使它不如做其他可能更强烈吸引注意力的活动那样令人享受。我们一直在讨论我们如何受到户外所见之物的影像，但你的研究着眼于大自然的声音以及它们如何产生影响。马克，你发现了什么？
So we found that just listening to nature sounds versus urban sounds, you can get some of these same benefits as walking in nature. So you can get these improvements on tasks like the backwards digit span task and other cognitive tasks that involve directed attention, that just listening to about 10 minutes of nature sounds can improve performance on these tasks. And I would mention that we find you get the strongest benefits typically when going out in real nature, likely because real nature is more softly fascinating.
所以我们发现，仅仅听自然声音与城市声音相比，你就能获得与在大自然中散步类似的一些益处。因此，你可以在倒序数字广度测试以及其他涉及直接注意力的认知任务上获得这些提升，仅仅听大约10分钟的自然声音就能提高这些任务的表现。我想提一下，我们发现当你走到真正的大自然中时，通常会获得最强烈的益处，这可能是因为真正的大自然更能温和地吸引注意力。
It's got the sights, the sounds, maybe even the smells or the textures that might be beneficial to us. But it's interesting because a lot of us don't have access to real nature. It's interesting that you can get some of these same improvements with simulated nature, like nature sounds or nature pictures or nature videos. Do you think doctors should be prescribing nature the way they now prescribe medications, Mark? Well, in some countries, they already are. In the UK, they're prescribing nature walks as a therapy for depression and anxiety. In Canada, they're also prescribing nature walks as a therapy for depression and anxiety.
它有视觉、声音，甚至可能是气味或质感，这些都可能对我们有益。但这很有趣，因为我们很多人无法接触到真正的大自然。有趣的是，你可以通过模拟自然获得一些相同的改善，比如自然声音、自然图片或自然视频。马克，你认为医生应该像现在开处方药一样开出“自然处方”吗？嗯，在某些国家，他们已经这么做了。在英国，他们将自然漫步作为治疗抑郁和焦虑的疗法。在加拿大，他们也将自然漫步作为治疗抑郁和焦虑的疗法。
I don't think anyone yet would say that interacting with nature would be a replacement therapy for psychotherapy or pharmacological therapies for depression and anxiety, but it certainly could be a supplemental therapy. And people have also found that interacting with nature can be really helpful for kids with ADHD, that brief interactions with nature like 20 minutes walk in nature can be as beneficial as a dose of riddlein. So I think the research is definitely not there yet in terms of having interactions with nature be a replacement for any validated forms of therapy for depression and anxiety. But I do think there's already becoming evidence and doctors are already starting to take
我认为现在没有人会说与大自然互动可以替代心理治疗或针对抑郁和焦虑的药物治疗，但它绝对可以作为一种补充疗法。人们还发现，与大自然互动对患有多动症（ADHD）的儿童非常有用，短暂的自然互动，比如在大自然中散步20分钟，可以和一剂利他林（Ritalin）一样有效。所以我认为，就让自然互动取代任何经过验证的抑郁和焦虑治疗方法而言，研究还绝对没有达到那个阶段。但我确实认为，已经有越来越多的证据表明，医生也开始认真对待
this work seriously that interactions with nature could be a supplement to existing therapies for like depression and anxiety. You know, I remember once taking the elevator to the top of the Washington monument here in Washington, D.C., and from that height in my home city looking north, I could see that one quadrant of my city was very green and leafy, while the other quadrant that I could see was really barren. Now, the leafy quadrant happened to also be one of the richest parts of Washington, D.C., and the barren portion happened to be one of the poorer parts of Washington, D.C. Can you talk a moment about how our access to nature is often connected to our
这项研究，即与大自然的互动可以作为抑郁和焦虑等现有疗法的补充。你知道，我记得有一次乘电梯登上华盛顿特区的华盛顿纪念碑顶端，从我所在的这个城市的这个高度向北望去，我可以看到我城市的其中一个象限非常绿树成荫，郁郁葱葱，而我能看到的另一个象限则非常荒凉。现在，这个绿树成荫的象限碰巧也是华盛顿特区最富有的地区之一，而荒凉的部分碰巧是华盛顿特区较贫穷的地区之一。你能谈谈我们接触大自然的机会如何通常与我们的
socioeconomic status, that access to nature is becoming one more way in which social inequality can manifest itself? Right. Unfortunately, there is a correlation between socioeconomic and access to green space. And you see that in a lot of cities in the U.S., for example. And, you know, there's a lot of different reasons why that might be the case. And even people have found that, you know, red-lined neighborhoods have less green space and less biodiversity than non-red-line neighborhoods. So there's deep historical reasons for a lot of this. The air might be cleaner and wealthier neighborhoods. There's likely less pollutants in wealthier neighborhoods than poor neighborhoods. And I think it's sort of an environmental justice issue that this isn't just a nice
社会经济地位息息相关吗？即接触大自然正在成为社会不平等体现的又一种方式？没错。不幸的是，社会经济状况与绿地可及性之间存在相关性。例如，你在美国的许多城市都能看到这一点。而且，你知道，造成这种情况的原因有很多。甚至有人发现，历史上被划为红线（歧视性住房政策）的neighborhood（街区）比未被划为红线的neighborhood绿地更少，生物多样性也更少。因此，这里面有着深厚的历史原因。富裕地区的空气可能更干净。富裕地区的污染物可能比贫穷地区少。我认为这有点像环境正义问题，这不仅仅是富人拥有的一项美好的
amenity that wealthy people have. This is something fundamental to all humans that we need to have access to these natural spaces and if we don't have it, people are going to suffer.
便利设施。这是所有人基本的需求，我们需要接触这些自然空间，如果我们没有，人们就会受苦。
I understand that you and your wife, Katie, had a difficult decision to make a number of years ago when the two of you were living in Michigan. What was this decision and how did nature end up playing a role in helping you make this decision, Mark. I had a job offer in New Jersey of a professorship.
我了解到，几年前你和你的妻子凯蒂住在密歇根州时，曾面临一个艰难的决定。这是一个什么样的决定？马克，大自然最终是如何在帮助你做出这个决定中发挥作用的？我在新泽西州得到了一份教授的工作Offer。
You know, they're very hard to come by. I really wanted to take the job. But my, you know, wife, Katie and I, we were pregnant at the time, too. And Katie just felt uncomfortable kind of going to a new place where we didn't have family to have our child there. So she wanted to go back and be near family in Toronto. know. And it was a very difficult decision. We were arguing a lot about it. It was a very challenging time. But we did often talk about this difficult decision in nature. And I remember
你知道，这很难得。我真的很想接受这份工作。但我的妻子凯蒂和我，当时也怀孕了。凯蒂觉得去一个没有家人、无法在那里生孩子的新地方很不舒服。所以她想回到多伦多，在家人身边。你知道的。这是一个非常艰难的决定。我们为此争论了很多。那是一段非常具有挑战性的时期。但我们确实经常在大自然中讨论这个艰难的决定。我记得
walking through the botanical gardens a number of times with Katie, you know, talking about all the pros and cons of it. I don't think these were necessarily restorative walks in nature. But again, I think being in nature afforded us some directed attention benefits and we did decide that I would give up this job and that we would
和凯蒂一起多次漫步在植物园里，讨论着所有的利弊。我认为这些不一定是大自然中的恢复性散步。但同样，我认为身处大自然赋予了我们一些直接注意力的好处，我们确实决定我将放弃这份工作，并且我们会
I would try to get a postdoc job in Toronto and we would have our first child in Toronto I do remember one time too on one of these walks as we were in the botanical gardens we did see a turtle like burying her eggs
尝试在多伦多找到一份博士后工作，我们的第一个孩子也会在多伦多出生。我也确实记得有一次在其中的一次散步中，当我们走在植物园里时，我们看到了一只海龟正在小路上
on the path and I think you know, it just kind of made me think, you know, while this is very hard to give up this job and these jobs are very difficult to come by focusing more on the family and what would make the family most comfortable, what would be the best environment for the family, was probably the best decision. Swimming in the ocean, tromping through a field, or wandering through a forest, can do wonders for our mental clarity and our attention span.
产卵埋蛋。我想你知道，这让我觉得，虽然放弃这份工作很难，而且这些工作很难得，但把更多精力放在家庭上，以及什么能让家庭最舒适、什么对家庭来说是最好的环境，可能是最好的决定。在大海中畅游、在田野里跋涉或在森林中漫游，可以为我们的精神清晰度和注意力广度创造奇迹。
But most of us spend the bulk of our time inside buildings. When we come back, bringing the benefits of nature indoors. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. We're talking today to psychologist Mark Berman about nature's effect on the mind. If you have follow-up questions, comments, or stories about your experience of nature that you would be comfortable sharing with the Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org.
但我们大多数人的大部分时间都是在建筑物内部度过的。稍后回来，将大自然的好处带到室内。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。今天我们与心理学家马克·伯曼探讨大自然对心灵的影响。如果你有后续问题、评论或关于你接触大自然的经历的故事，并愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享，请在手机上录制语音备忘录，并发送至 ideas at hiddenbrain.org。
Use the subject line, Nature. Mark Berman has spent years studying how outdoors, spaces influence us. But the fact is that many of us spend most of our time indoors. Is it possible to reap the rewards of nature from within a building or even inside a car? Mark, you say that we can intentionally natureize our interior spaces, bring elements of nature indoors. Before we talk about the how, let's talk about the why. Why would we do this? Well, we would do this because we find that even having plants, even if they're artificial plants in our homes, in our offices can also lead to some benefits. So, and oftentimes it's hard to bring real nature into indoor spaces.
请使用主题行：Nature（自然）。马克·伯曼花了很多年研究户外空间如何影响我们。但事实是，我们许多人把大部分时间都花在室内。有没有可能在建筑物内部甚至在车内收获大自然的恩赐？马克，你说过我们可以刻意将室内空间“自然化”，把大自然的元素带到室内。在我们讨论“如何”之前，先谈谈“为什么”。我们为什么要这样做？嗯，我们这样做是因为我们发现，即使在我们的家或办公室里摆放植物，哪怕是人造植物，也能带来一些好处。而且，通常很难将真正的大自然带入室内空间。
Maybe we don't have enough natural light or it's difficult to water plants on a regular schedule. But it's interesting to note that other researchers have found that bringing nature indoors, even if it's fake nature, can have some of these similar benefits. Talk about how you yourself have tried to natureize the spaces in which you live and work. Well, right now I'm in my home office. I actually have two plants behind me. They're actually artificial plants. Those aren't real plants. They look fairly real, which I think is good, but I don't have enough natural light here to actually get real plants in the office. In other portions of our house, we do actually have real plants.
也许我们没有足够的自然光，或者很难按照规律的时间表给植物浇水。但有趣的是，其他研究人员发现，把大自然带到室内，哪怕是假的大自然，也能产生类似的一些好处。谈谈你自己是如何尝试将你生活和工作空间自然化的。嗯，现在我正在我的家庭办公室里。我其实在我身后放了两株植物。它们其实是人造植物。那些不是真正的植物。它们看起来相当逼真，我认为这很好，但我这里没有足够的自然光来真正在办公室里养植物。在我们房子的其他部分，我们确实有真正的植物。
So we get some nice light through one of our bay windows. We have a few different plants there. So we try to bring in real nature where we can into our home and where we can't. We usually utilize some fake nature. It also so happens that my mother-in-law, is a little bit of an artist. My sister is a little bit of an artist. We've commissioned them to make some nature paintings that we have hanging in our home. So there are many different kinds of things that we can do. Some of my kids actually like to sleep with a sound machine. Often we use
所以我们通过其中一个凸窗获得了一些很好的光线。我们在那里放了几种不同的植物。所以我们尽量把真正的大自然带进我们的家中，实在做不到的地方，我们通常会利用一些假的大自然。碰巧的是，我的岳母有点像个艺术家。我姐姐也有点像个艺术家。我们委托他们创作了一些自然主题的画作，挂在我们家里。所以我们可以做很多不同种类的的事情。我的几个孩子其实喜欢伴着声音机睡觉。通常我们会在
nature sounds for them to be playing in the background to help them, help them sleep. So I think there's a number of different things that we can do to nature our spaces. I understand that one time you were visiting your parents in Detroit, and you found that an airport hotel had found a way to natureize its indoor spaces. Tell me about this experience. Yeah, it was pretty cool. So in Detroit Metro Airport, kind of like off to the side, there's the Weston Hotel. And I remember my dad telling me that it's an interesting spot to check out.
背景中播放自然的声音来帮助他们，帮助他们入睡。所以我认为我们可以做很多不同的事情来让我们的空间自然化。我听说有一次你去看望底特律的父母时，发现一家机场酒店找到了将室内空间自然化的方法。能讲讲这段经历吗？是的，这非常酷。所以在底特律大都会机场，有点像在旁边，有一家威斯汀酒店。我记得我爸爸告诉我这是一个值得去看看的有趣地方。
So I remember taking the escalator down, and it was incredible. They had these fake bamboo trees that were out in the lobby of the Weston Hotel and also some water features. And even though it was fake, it almost felt like you were in a different world. And you could feel almost the restorative power of these natural elements, even though a lot of them were fake. And so every time that I would go to the Detroit airport, I would often try to go to the Weston Hotel. and there was a little actually TSA security gate there so you could go through security there. And I would try to do that on a regular basis
所以我记得我乘自动扶梯下去，那真是太不可思议了。威斯汀酒店的大堂里摆放着这些人造的竹子，还有一些水景。尽管那是假的，但几乎让你感觉置身于一个不同的世界。你几乎能感受到这些自然元素带来的恢复力量，尽管它们很多都是假的。所以每次我去底特律机场，我经常会尝试去威斯汀酒店。那里其实有一个小型的TSA安全检查口，你可以在那里过安检。我会定期尝试这样做
so I could get exposed to that kind of very interesting natural environment that they had created in the lobby of the Weston Hotel. I've noticed that as I go through airports nowadays, that some of them are making a deliberate attempt to bring the outdoors indoors. And sometimes, as you say, this is fake nature. I've sometimes flown through the airport in Doha in Qatar, and they have reimagined an entire section of the airport to make it look like almost like a wildlife habitat.
这样我就可以接触到他们在威斯汀酒店大堂里创造的那种非常有趣的自然环境。我注意到现在的机场，有些机场正在刻意尝试将户外搬到室内。正如你所说，有时这是假的大自然。我有几次飞经卡塔尔多哈机场，他们重新设计了机场的整个区域，使其看起来几乎像一个野生动物栖息地。
Now, there are some actual trees, but the grass is really just green carpeting. But I find that it's very restorative to stop in this area during stopovers on a long flight. Yes, and I've seen it too. Even airports now are starting to have kind of green walls. Oftentimes it's also kind of near security, and I'm wondering if they have it in there to kind of calm people down as they're waiting in line to go through. these security checks. So I think a lot of these airport designers are having the intuition that incorporating some nature into the airport is going to be beneficial. And people have tried to do similar things in hospitals where, again, oftentimes in hospitals, the environment is
现在，有一些真正的树木，但草其实只是绿色的地毯。但我发现在漫长飞行的中途停留期间，在这个区域停留是非常具有恢复力的。是的，我也见过。现在连机场也开始有某种绿化墙了。通常它也靠近安检处，我在想他们把它放在那里是不是为了让人们在排队过安检时平静下来。所以我认为许多机场设计者都有这种直觉，即把一些大自然融入机场将是有益的。人们试图在医院里做类似的事情，同样的，很多时候医院的环境是
requires to be sterile, but it has to be sterile. But people have brought in fake nature into hospitals, and they found that it can reduce pain for people that are getting painful operations. They can make people feel like they're staying in the hospitals more enjoyable. And this is even when they know, the patients know, that the plants are fake. And they can also have benefits to the people working in the hospital, that it can maybe help to give them these, as Rachel Kaplan would say, these micro doses of nature. They could give them these little boosts of directed attention. Very often when we're trying to get somewhere,
要求无菌的，但它必须是无菌的。但人们把假的大自然带进了医院，他们发现这可以减轻正在接受痛苦手术的人的痛感。这可以让人们觉得他们在医院的滞留更加愉快。即使患者知道这些植物是假的，也是如此。而且这也能对在医院工作的人带来好处，也许可以帮助赋予他们罗杰·卡普兰（Rachel Kaplan）所说的微剂量大自然。这可以给他们提供这些对注意力的微小提升。很多时候，当我们试图去某个地方时，
we focus on getting from point A to point B as quickly and efficiently as possible. Mark, you say that we should be asking how green our route can be, and in fact, you're exploring the development of an app to help people identify the most nature-filled way to walk somewhere. Right, and this is work that I've done in collaboration.
我们会专注于尽可能高效地从A点到达B点。马克，你说过我们应该问问我们的路线可以有多绿，事实上，你正在探索开发一款应用程序，帮助人们识别去某处最充满自然气息的步行方式。没错，这是我与合作者共同完成的工作。
collaboration with one of my former students, Kate Shirts, where we developed this app called Retune, so restoring through urban nature experiences. And, you know, if you go on Google Maps, it's going to route you on the shortest or most efficient path between point A to point B. But what we try to do with Retune is try to map people on the walking route that will increase their nature exposure, so that would increase the number of trees that they would be exposed to, reduce the amount of noise that they would be exposed to. And so what happens with this app is that the path that it might suggest for you might be a little bit longer, but you would be exposed to more of this softly fascinating natural stimulation that we think would
与我的一位前学生凯特·舍茨（Kate Shirts）合作，我们开发了一款名为 Retune 的应用程序，即通过城市自然体验恢复精力（restoring through urban nature experiences）。而且，如果你用谷歌地图，它会为你规划从A点到B点最短或最高效的路线。但我们用 Retune 尝试做的是，为人们规划能增加他们自然接触的步行路线，这会增加他们接触到的树木数量，减少他们接触到的噪音。所以这款应用程序的作用是，它为你推荐的路径可能会稍微长一点，但你会接触到更多这种温和吸引注意力的自然刺激，我们认为这会
boost cognitive abilities. Mark, you found yourself inspired by certain buildings that incorporate elements of nature. Talk about this, how architecture in some ways can itself be a way of bringing nature indoors. Yeah, it's really interesting to think about how some of these nature results also might relate to architecture. And, you know, one thing, I don't know if you've ever been to the campus of the University of Chicago, but it's a very beautiful campus, in part because the buildings are just beautiful. These beautiful Gothic architecture buildings that actually mimic a lot of the patterns in nature.
提升认知能力。马克，你发现自己从一些融入了自然元素的建筑中获得了灵感。谈谈这个，建筑在某些方面本身如何成为一种将大自然带入室内的方式？是的，思考其中一些自然结果可能与建筑有怎样的关联，这真的很有趣。而且，你知道，一件事，我不知道你是否去过芝加哥大学的校园，但那是一个非常美丽的校园，部分原因是因为这些建筑本身就很美。这些美丽的哥特式建筑实际上模仿了许多自然界的图案。
There's a lot of intricacy to the buildings. They have some of the same fractal or scale-free components that real nature has. They have a lot of the curved edge structure that real nature has. And it just feels like it's possible that it might be having some cognitive benefits to us. And I had an architecture student, Alex Coburn, contact me where he was interested in seeing if buildings, building facades or building interiors, if they mimic patterns in nature, did they also yield some benefits?
这些建筑有很多错综复杂的设计。它们具有与真实自然相同的分形或无标度组件。它们拥有真实自然所具有的许多曲边结构。这让人觉得，它有可能对我们的认知产生一些益处。有一位建筑系学生亚历克斯·科本（Alex Coburn）联系了我，他有兴趣看看建筑、建筑立面或建筑内部，如果它们模仿自然界的图案，是否也会产生一些益处？
So he and I and a few other people designed some studies where we had people look at different architectural facades. You know, these would be buildings for hospitals or religious buildings or government buildings. And in those buildings, we also quantified how fractal the buildings were, how much curved edge structure the buildings had. And basically what we found was that the buildings had more curved edge structure, had more fractalness. People said they liked the buildings more and that they actually thought that the buildings were more natural than buildings that were sort of more.
所以他、我和其他几个人设计了一些研究，让人们观察不同的建筑立面。你知道，这些可能是医院建筑、宗教建筑或政府建筑。在这些建筑中，我们还量化了建筑的“分形度”，以及建筑具有多少曲边结构。基本上我们发现的是，那些具有更多曲边结构、更多分形特征的建筑，人们表示更喜欢这些建筑，并且他们实际上认为这些建筑比那些
rectilinear that had just straight lines and the same was also true of building interiors so just like not all nature is created equal not all of the built environment is created equal and it does have me thinking or wondering whether even without actually using any real nature if we designed the built environment with a lot of these natural patterns could that yield some of these cognitive benefits. And the architect, Christopher Alexander, you know, wrote many books about this, encouraging architects to try to mimic patterns of nature in their architecture, that that would lead to more vibrant buildings that would make people feel more connected to the environment,
只有直线条的、更偏向直角直线的建筑更自然。建筑内部也是如此：正如并非所有的自然都是生而平等的，并非所有的建筑环境也是生而平等的，这确实让我思考或好奇，即使不实际使用任何真正的大自然，如果我们用许多这些自然图案来设计建筑环境，是否能产生一些这样的认知益处。建筑师克里斯托弗·Alexander（Christopher Alexander）写了许多关于这方面的书，鼓励建筑师在建筑中尝试模仿大自然的图案，这将带来更有生气的建筑，让人们感觉与环境联系更紧密，
but might also induce some different psychological benefits. And I do remember one time my colleague, Candace Vogler, who's a philosopher, she joked with me one time that the Durham Chapel at Duke is so beautiful that it does the praying for you. And, you know, I kind of wonder, you know, is the architecture, you know, at the University of Chicago, you know, so grand does it do the studying, you know, for you. And, you know, and I remember being a student at the University of Michigan, and I would often try to study in the law library that had this really grand and intricate reading room versus studying in the undergraduate library that was called the ugly, because the law library just felt so much better to be in there with all of that
但也可能会引发一些不同的心理益处。我确实记得有一次我的同事坎迪斯·沃格勒（Candace Vogler），她是一位哲学家，她曾开玩笑对我说，杜克大学的杜勒姆教堂太美了，它甚至替你完成了祈祷。而且，你知道，我有点好奇，你知道，芝加哥大学的建筑是否如此宏伟，以至于它替你完成了学习？而且，你知道，我记得作为密歇根大学的学生，我经常试图在法律图书馆学习，那里有一个非常宏伟且错综复杂的阅览室，相比之下，在那个被称为“丑陋建筑”的本科生图书馆学习，因为法律图书馆里有着所有那些美丽的建筑，待在那里感觉要好得多。
beautiful architecture. In our companion story to this episode, available exclusively to the subscribers to Hidden Brain Plus, we explore the ways in which nature can help us curb our impulsive and aggressive urges. If you're a subscriber, that episode is available right now. It's titled Into the Woods. If you're not yet a subscriber, please visit support.hiddenbrain.org or apple.com slash hiddenbrain. You can get a free seven-day trial in both places. You'll instantly have access to all our subscriber-only content, including past episodes. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org or apple.com slash hidden brain.
在本期节目的配套报道中，该报道仅向《隐藏的大脑加点》（Hidden Brain Plus）的订阅者独家提供，我们将探讨大自然如何帮助我们抑制冲动和攻击性冲动。如果您是订阅者，该集节目现在即可收听。它的标题是《深入树林》（Into the Woods）。如果您还不是订阅者，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 或 apple.com slash hiddenbrain。您可以在这两个地方获得七天免费试用。您将立即访问我们所有仅限订阅者的内容，包括过往剧集。再次说明，网址是 support.hiddenbrain.org 或 apple.com slash hiddenbrain。
Mark Berman is a psychologist at the University of Chicago. He's the author of Nature and the Mind, the science of how nature improves cognitive, physical, and social well-being. Mark, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me on the show. I really enjoyed it. If you like this episode, please share it with one or two people. Many of our listeners discover the show because someone else told them about it. Please think of a few people who would benefit from hearing the episode and tell them to search for Hidden Brain on Apple, Spotify, or their favorite podcast app.
马克·伯曼是芝加哥大学的心理学家。他是《自然与心灵：大自然如何改善认知、身体和社交健康的科学》一书的作者。马克，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我上节目。我真的很享受。如果你喜欢这期节目，请与一两位朋友分享。我们的许多听众都是因为别人向他们推荐才发现这个节目的。请想想有哪几位朋友会从中受益，并告诉他们在苹果、声田（Spotify）或他们最喜欢的播客应用上搜索《隐藏的大脑》。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Laura Correll, Kristen Wong, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Before we go today, we wanted to say thank you to Loom by Atlassian for sponsoring the Hidden Brain 2025 perceptions tour. With Loom, teams move work forward faster, replacing. endless meetings and slow approvals with quick, clear video messages. Today, we'll hear from Dr. Molly Sands, head of the teamwork lab at Atlassian, about how
《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗（Annie Murphy Paul）、劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）、克里斯滕·黄（Kristen Wong）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制作人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。在今天的节目结束前，我们要感谢 Atlassian 的 Loom 对《隐藏的大脑》2025年感知之旅的赞助。通过 Loom，团队可以更快地推进工作，用快捷、清晰的视频消息取代没完没了的会议和缓慢的审批。今天，我们将听到 Atlassian 团队合作实验室负责人莫莉·桑兹（Molly Sands）博士的发言，了解
Loom is transforming the way teams work. I'm Dr. Molly Sands, and I lead the teamwork lab at Atlassian, which is our future of work research and innovation group. If I could wave the magic wand and change something about teamwork, I would stop teams from using meetings for every single thing. I wish teams would embrace asynchronous communication, so sharing updates or feedback in ways that don't require everyone to drop what they're doing at the same time. Loom is a video messaging platform that lets you quickly record and share updates, walkthroughs,
Loom 如何改变团队的工作方式。我是莫莉·桑兹博士，我领导 Atlassian 的团队合作实验室，这是我们的未来工作研究与创新小组。如果我能挥动魔杖改变团队合作的一件事，我会阻止团队在每件小事上都开会。我希望团队能够拥抱异步沟通，即以不需要每个人同时放下手头工作的方式分享更新或反馈。Loom 是一个视频消息平台，可让你快速录制和分享更新、演练
or feedback without scheduling another meeting. The magic of Loom is that it feels really personal. like someone tapping you on the shoulder, but it's actually asynchronous. Lou makes it very easy for teams to share and get the information they need in last time. And the more that teams use Loom to communicate and to capture conversations, the smarter their AI-enabled knowledge bases get. It lets people design their day around their energy and around their priorities instead of being trapped by their meeting schedule.
或反馈，而无需安排另一场会议。Loom 的神奇之处在于它感觉非常个人化。就像有人轻拍你的肩膀，但它实际上是异步的。Loom 让团队可以非常轻松地在更短的时间内分享和获取所需的信息。团队越是使用 Loom 进行沟通和记录对话，他们由人工智能驱动的知识库就会变得越聪明。它让人们根据自己的精力和优先事项来设计自己的一天，而不是被会议日程所束缚。
LUMM is AI-powered video communication that moves teams forward. Whether you're sharing feedback, obtaining approvals, or setting context, LUMM makes it easy for teams to share and collaborate on work. Save time and stay focused on what matters without another meeting. Try Lume today at loom. That's L-O-O-O-M.com. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Loom 是由人工智能驱动的视频沟通工具，能推动团队不断向前。无论你是在分享反馈、获取审批还是设定背景，Loom 都能让团队轻松共享和协作工作。无需再开会，节省时间并专注于重要的事情。今天就去 loom 体验 Loom 吧，网址是 L-O-O-O-M.com。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们很快再见。本集节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。